hello and welcome to a very special live
episode of trigonometry i'm francis
foster i'm constantine kitten and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people we
are here live with our brilliant and
returning guest it's one calvin robinson
welcome back man thank you thank you
honestly the most referenced show that
people talk to me about is your show
they say i've seen you on trigonometry i
first heard about you on trigonometry so
it's good to be back on this show all
right well you've managed to get
yourself cancelled yet again in your
life so you're back on the show
but it's been a busy it's been a busy
time for you and uh
just before we get into everything
that's been going on for people who are
not familiar who are tuning in maybe you
heard a bit of the story don't know who
you are just give everybody a little
refresh of your background where you're
coming from et cetera who i am in 30
seconds um i've been training for the
priesthood for holy orders in the church
of england for the last couple of years
reading theology at oxford
i present and sit on panels on gb news
and i occasionally write in in the
broadsheets and tabloids that sums up
the way i'm aware and you're a very
prominent conservative commentator uh
and i would say one of the things that i
find interesting about you is is
you comment on some of the cultural
stuff that we also talk about but you do
it from a very
a very restrained place you're not some
massive culture warrior who's going
around being provocative for the sake of
it which i think probably reflects the
faith journey of that you're on as well
so you you've come into prominence here
again in the last week
because you've had some issues with the
church of england in which you were
training so just give everybody the the
whole story from the beginning so i
think you've hit the nail on the head
there and that i do comment on the
culture wars but from a faith
perspective it's all about the faith for
me it's all about putting christ at the
center of everything that i do and i
fight the good fight for that reason
because i think that our society is
running down the wrong direction and it
has been for the last few years it's
chasing wokeness unfortunately i believe
the church is also going down that path
in so many ways you know i i think i
mentioned last time i was on about
churches closing throughout the pandemic
in a time when there was a great need
for people to have someone looking out
for their spiritual well-being and the
churches said we're not just closing to
the people we're closing to priests you
can no longer come in and pray for your
parishioners
um we've seen that cathedrals have said
you can only come in if you've got a
medical mandate to not use key
technology that's going to trigger your
your platform
um
we've seen the church take on board
critical race theory
so this is something that i opposed
quite loudly in that they put out a
report called lament to action
which took on board whole load of
critical race theory language anti-white
sentiments you know quotas for ethnic
minorities all of this kind of stuff i
said this is incompatible with our faith
why i get that there's a there's a topic
of conversation here that's not just
national but global around black lives
matter we have to be a part of it of
course we do because we're faith based
on justice
but we can't take on board neo-marxist
ideologies in order to address the issue
in common you know the church they stood
up and said we are institutionally
racist without any evidence nothing to
back it up just we are deeply
institutionally racist these are the
words of the archbishop of country
now i said to to my bishop the bishop of
london i don't think that's appropriate
i think that's quite divisive because of
course there's so much racism going on
in the world and in the country and
potentially in the church
but that's individuals that's malicious
or ignorant individuals that need
you know
they need the consequences of their
actions need to be brought to them not
the entire institution don't paint us
all as racist unless you've got some
evidence to back that up then i'll hold
my hands up and say okay maybe it is
but you know the sewer report came out
the credit report that looked into
racism and racial disparities in our
country didn't find any evidence of
racial um
institutional racism doesn't mean it
didn't exist it didn't find any evidence
of it so i tend to go along with the
lines of that that racial disparities
aren't necessarily
a sign of racism but also things that we
need to address on a wider picture what
social economic factors at play tend to
be geography class background you know
what um
education all of these things come into
someone's
situation not just their skin color and
if we put it all down skin color we're
dismissing the wider image the wider
problem we can't actually solve it so i
said this and then you know the very
upper middle class white metropolitan
liberal elite bishop turned around and
he said the calvin
i can tell you as a white one the church
is institutionally racist and i'm like
okay
where do i go from here because it's
very difficult that level of not
cognitive dissonance but choice it's
it's a choice to take on board an
ideology and not to consider other
perspectives and part of the ideology is
actually you know taking on board the
lived experiences of ethnic minorities
and i as an ethnic minority i'm standing
up there saying i want to give you my
lift experience they're saying no no
that's the wrong type of lived
experience
just as they're always saying you know
you're the wrong type of black we want
the black people that we can pat on the
head and say good black person you're
falling in line with our with our way of
life and with our thinking i find it
patronizing almost to the point of
racism actually in order to
prove their point that the church is
institution racist they said actually
calvin we don't want to hear your point
of view and
said we don't want to see you anymore
you're gone
so calvin how long has the church been
following this path was it like a lot of
organizations and institutions it all
came to a head with george floyd and the
blm demonstrations already had it
already been going down that path for a
while it had already been going down
that path so i think it was 2017 when
the abc the archbishop of canterbury
stood up and said the church is
institutionally racist and then they put
up this lament to action report around
the time of black lives matter that
backed up that statement and pointed to
his
um his saying that in the general synod
as evidence and then they recently put
out a contested heritage report which
advises clergymen how to remove
potentially harmful statues and
monuments from their churches and said
that this country is institutionally
racist and it referred to the limit to
action report as evidence of that so
it's a cyclical you know leftist
approach to academia that evidence isn't
actually evidence it's all anecdotally
all points to each other
but this idea that
statues and monuments can be harmful
by just being there like that i get that
people can take offense to anything but
that's you know offences taken not
usually given especially with an
inanimate object like that but
these statues that we have up they're
usually honoring something that
someone's contributed to our society and
or they're usually
there to represent someone who's died
they're not there to say this was a
perfect human being
and in fact if you're a christian you
acknowledge that nobody's a perfect
human a human being there's only ever
been one person perfect person that was
jesus christ himself everyone else is
fallen everyone else is flawed
individuals so we all have pasts so this
idea that you know oh somewhere in his
past his great-grandfather had links to
the british empire therefore he needs to
be removed because this is colonialism
that's a nonsense that goes against the
faith and so does the whole of critical
race theory this idea that
white people are either overtly or
covertly racist
creates a new kind of original sin it's
a sin that only white people can commit
therefore again it's anti-christian
because we're all sinners but if there's
a sin that white people can only commit
and white people cannot escape either
it's overtly or covertly happening
then there's no repentance there's no
forgiveness and there's no salvation
again that's anti-christian all of this
goes against our faith you know even the
scripture itself in galatians or acts
when we hear that you know there's
neither jew nor greek or that we're all
made of one blood one nation
the christian idea is that we're united
our identity is in christ it's not in
our immutable characteristics our skin
color is irrelevant so the people that
are really pushing this and you know the
church has doubled down today actually
and
they've put out a statement saying we
double we re back our efforts uh to
support our anti-racism task force again
what's an anti-racist hospital so why
does a church have one sure the better
thing is for us all to just not be
racist
but it's that tribalism isn't it that
you've got to be in the anti-racism camp
otherwise you're not you must be a
racist it's like actually no let's take
a step back
let's look at the bigger picture you
know what the church has done
in these reports they've said you know
every leadership position in the church
must have
30 percent ukme people being put forward
on a short list
now ukme is the church's language for
b.a.m.e it's the uk minority ethnic
which is obviously same as black and
asian minority ethnics which is
basically not white if you're not white
you pot the same club you know
we're all we're all we all think like we
vote alike we talk like that's how they
see us
um but of course that's not true
but the idea that 30 of every leadership
position in the church of england needs
to have
an ethnic minority shortlist well
roughly 12 to 14 of the british
population is ethnic minority status but
half of them are muslim so that
let's get some muslims in the church of
england diversity of fault one vicar
held up the clock recently saying we are
all muslims now and i kind of think
that's the way we're going but that
leaves seven percent of the whole
population
if you're in somewhere like london
you've got a good chance of getting
thirty percent of shortness but if
you're somewhere up north or down south
not so much the case always so it's an
arbitrary number but then they're also
going down the roots of affirmative
action or positive discrimination and i
don't think there is any discrimination
that is positive but where in that um
they just had an election for the
general synod the governing body of the
church of england anyone could put
themselves up for election if they're a
member of the church and they're saying
actually we need to co-opt some brown
people on as well as if to suggest that
ethnic minorities can't put ourselves up
for election we're not clever enough to
do that or we don't believe in the
democratic process so they have to
co-opt five members on who happen to be
uk and me
that that's backwards thinking to me
that's you know
calvin look we agree with you on on this
show with all of that completely whether
it's we're neither of us
churchgoers but
it's a principle i think that applies
universally but what i think look people
are allowed to have different opinions
and if someone wants to believe in
critical race theory that is entirely up
to them right
the problem with your case from what i
can tell is
your views were quite well known within
the church and as you went through your
training for which the church which the
church subsidized to some extent as i
understand
actually people behind your back were
having conversations by email which
you've since discovered
about how you must be prevented from
advancing and all of that and to me
if people in the church of england
believe in critical race theory or want
to implement some of these progressive
work ideas you know it's a free country
do whatever you want the problem is when
people like you start to be excluded now
i know you will have your strength of
feeling about some of those ideologies
as as we both do as well
my point is what i'm getting at is it's
not so much the case that you know they
had these ideas and you had different
ideas it's that like with many other
institutions now and we see this across
the board
your ideas are not allowed to be had
that are not allowed to be expressed and
you have to be pushed out talk to us
about that i will i i would go a step
further and see if these ideas are
counter scriptural they have no place in
christianity so anyone can believe in
critical race though if they want to i
would say it has no place in the church
but my my argument has been silenced and
it came to the end of my training i'm
just finishing now and and
i i was put forward to a parish to be an
assistant priest
that got taken off that position got
taken away and i asked you know why
what's going on
one of the bishops and i won't mention
any names on here because i don't want
them to sue you but i'm happy for them
to sue me because i will just release
all the evidence and make it all public
but i don't want to see you guys but one
of the bishops said um
you know
it would be too turbulent calvin because
people might complain about your views i
was like well i like to think my viewers
are mostly christian and if you don't
think they are tell me which ones aren't
but if people are complaining about them
my christian views then surely i'm doing
something right but anyway show me the
complaints i'll try and improve my
practice and not be as offensive
and they refuse to show me so i put in a
subject access request
which enables me to see any
communication about me within the church
and that was a big surprise because i've
because this was all new to me that i
saw from these communications that
bishops have been talking behind my back
for the last couple of years before they
even sent me to training bear in mind
they just paid 20 grand to send me to
oxford and it's not their money it's the
money that the poor old ladies in the
pews that they've used to send me to
oxford
uh and before even sending me they
decided that they didn't want me to be
ordained and the biggest cause that i
could see from the communications is
calvin does not believe in institutional
racist racism there calvin does not
believe in institutional racism
therefore we should keep an eye on his
alternation process
nudge nudge wink wink it's the kind of
he does not agree with our politics
therefore do we really have a place for
him
and that that worries me because
obviously i've got a platform i can
expose all of this nonsense but what
about all the other conservatives what
about all the whether politically or
theologically conservative that have
been silenced and pushed out and since
i've spoken up i've had so many people
like
lay members you know people in the
congregations but also clergymen priests
that have reached out and said you know
this is happening to me i can't speak
out because i'm relying on the stipend
you know i get starved out or i've been
bullied out because of this i can't talk
about it yet because my case is still
ongoing it's
ripeness everywhere and it's so
demoralizing and you know
it's very upsetting and i use that word
purposefully because the one of the
bishops has come out today with a
statement so in all the media they
haven't given any statements otherwise
other than there's no place for calvin
because we don't have enough slots in
london we have spaces in london which is
an outright lie because i had a space
that was taken away and then many
priests that have offered me spaces to
train with them since but anyway that's
the statement they put out until today
one bishop has put out a statement in
the church times which is the mouthpiece
of the church of england because it's
reliant on the money from the
institution it's very much establishment
uh liberal liberal media and one of the
bishops put out a statement
saying that
actually
calvin is um
well not not trying to get too personal
but calvin is um
incorrect on this or my understanding of
these conversations was incorrect i'm
like okay sure i'll put all the
information out there but i lost my
train of thought on where i was going
with it
you're talking about the church times
and the statement that they put out
today so before that they were saying
that there's no space for you but now
they've said something different
yeah yeah
anyway we'll come back to it the thing i
was going to ask you live television
yeah
it's like gb news here um no um
the thing i was going to ask you kevin
is i i'm not a christian i don't
understand how these things work but i
would have thought
that if if i think of priests or
preachers off the top of my head that i
think of that i i would recall i'd
imagine quite a few of them would have
had offensive views for some people in
the society at the time in which they
expressed them probably starting with
jesus himself i would have thought let
me pull you there before i forget what
i've just remembered yeah i use the word
upset and i'm very upset about this
situation but what the statement that
the bishop put out through the church
times and bearing in mind they haven't
put a statement out anywhere else not in
the telegraph of the times the mail on
sunday the express but they chose the
church times put out a statement saying
i'm sad to hear that calvin is very
angry about the situation
like it's the gas lighting one of you
ever seen me angry ever
like that's not how i put myself across
and that's in line with you know when
i've had conversations with them saying
that i find this all very disappointing
because it's not in line with our
teaching and they'll say look calvin
it's not what you say it's how you say
it and i find that so annoying because i
try to at least be compassionate i try
to be very moderate so i'm not one of
these people that's very shouty or you
know going over the top so it i don't
think that's the truth i think it's a
dishonesty don't you think what's very
interesting is
i would see you as a classical
conservative
and to be
religious means a lot of the time you
are conservative by nature so in many
ways you're just reflecting the views of
your parishioners who are both religious
and conservative i don't understand what
is controversial about that trying to
i'll draw both of your questions
together because i think jesus christ
was controversial
i think he rebuked people quite often
said you're wrong on that you know he
was polite but he was he was very abrupt
said that's wrong this is the way
because he is the truth
and you know he actually he did get
quite angry at times and turned up the
tables in the temple when you know money
laundering was going on um
i do think his statement was
controversial i think his whole message
is controversial it's actually the most
scandalous message in human history that
you know god came to earth as man
incarnate and died for our sins for our
salvation it's quite out there um i
don't know if we can
tell the story without being
controversial and you know the bishops
say you've got to appease everybody
you've got to be more peaceable and
i don't think you can appease everyone i
think it's a divisive message
and we're here to warn people uh of
what's to come and to warn people away
from badness and point them towards
goodness to point them towards christ
it's quite simple but it is divisive it
is controversial
i completely agree with you but let's
focus on that point about your views how
we got to a place where a person can
have mainstream conservative opinions
that reflect his parishioners and at the
same time be forced out of the church
because small c conservative views or
there might be mainstream and they might
be in the majority but of course it's a
silent majority still and the very vocal
minority of the the liberal elites or
the woke people
is seen as the the normative and we i
mean we know it's not because you get so
many people contacting you on a daily
basis to say
what their views are but when all you
see in here in the mainstream media and
in politics is that liberal elite
perspective that metropolitan liberal
perspective people start to believe it
is the appropriate one to have in a
public space
and you know people have compared me to
other
um trainee priests that have been
uh going through similar stuff so
there's another
uh black or ethnic minority uh person
who got ordained last year actually that
put out a statement again i won't
mention any names but he put out a
statement saying that the cul the the
whole idea about celebrating sir captain
tom moore for raising was it 32 million
for the nhs amazing what a great man
what a patriot you know served our
country more than once but said that
that was a cult of white nationalism
suggesting this white supremacy to
support this church
30 000 people put a petition together to
say please don't ordain this man because
he's a racist yeah the church not only
ordained him they've encouraged him
supported him right and actually so this
guy is getting ordained you're getting
kicked out
because he sees the right sort of racism
he sees anyone that's white as racist
and sees this this country is racist and
i don't think that's true i think
individuals are racist and they need to
be held responsible for their actions so
callum what is this about really because
you know i've watched a few like yuri
bessement of lectures about
demoralization and all of that and i
can't help but think that if the church
is going down this path we really have
got to a point where all the
institutions and the systems and the
structures that were designed to keep
the good things about the society that
we have in place now look no one i
certainly would argue that society
doesn't need to move forward and adjust
to the times and grow as technologically
we grow and you know
embed all of that into how we live our
lives but i also think tradition and
history and past and all of these things
have value too
and yet we are seeing across every
industry now it seems in every field and
every element of our lives this creep
uh of these new ideas that are
undermining and destroying those things
what do you think this is about
i think progress isn't linear i think we
can go down lots of different routes in
life but that's how we get you to say
well it's 2022 of course xyz should be
the case as if like because it's this
year we're better than everyone in the
past of course we should think this but
europe's monologue was absolutely right
as was gramsci as with this whole idea
of the long watch through the
institutions and the centrism it has
taken place you know i can see it in
front of my eyes we're talking about the
church today so i'll use that as an
example out of 116 bishops only one of
them
overtly put therefore their case for
brexit the rest of them were either
silent on brexit or overtly supporting
remain so there's a massive disconnect
between them and the general public but
even amongst people within the church
the congregations 70 of normal laity
voted for brexit so that's even that's
even more than the general public so
that disconnects is very very clear
there but you know yuri besamov talks
about this this entrism and what's going
on and how they're going to infiltrate
our public institutions our public
bodies in the church it's not just the
bishops it's the people who select the
bishops
in this country it's down to one
individual to put forward names for
bishops technically speaking her majesty
the queen chooses the bishops on
recommendation of the prime minister but
that's not how it works in practice one
individual civil servant puts forward
the names and this is because gordon
brown was embarrassed about you know
being a scottish presbyterian
responsible for bishops in the church of
england so he stepped back from it and
obviously our monarchy is now
constitutional so she doesn't make an
active decision
so this civil servant who's just retired
after 17 years and we've got even worse
one in now has been putting forward
liberal names for bishops constantly
over the last two decades and that's why
the role of a group think you know if
they're in echo chamber they have a
group think mentality but don't you
think calvin that this is
a perfect example that
church and politics shouldn't mix
the church shouldn't get involved in
politics in any shape or form
yes and no i think you know the reason
we have the lord's spiritual in the
houses of parliament is because they're
supposed to be the moral compass of the
nation and if the government is putting
forward something that's anti-christian
the lord's spiritual is supposed to say
well you know this this is a more moral
case
um because it's still supposed to be a
christian country whether people want it
to be or not but they're not doing that
they are getting party political and the
bishops are campaigning against
government
policy because it's conservative you
know like the rwanda plan and saying
it's ungodly and then they're moralizing
that the special cove medicine and
saying you have to be a good christian
you have to take this um
so did they really say that yeah yeah to
be a good christian if you love your
neighbor you will take the special
medicine
that's inappropriate that's overreach
jab for jesus
that's wrong you know people should have
an individual right to make a choice
based on the data available for that
particular medicine there wasn't a lot
of data available so i understand why
some people chose not to take it but the
church has no place to say to be a good
christian you have to that makes me sick
but it's all over the place it's in
every issue it's in trans it's in race
it's in gender it's in sexuality
do you think part of the problem is that
and look we're not just talking about
the church of england here we're also
gonna
invoke my voice the catholic church
you look at the history of a lot of the
church
and there's quite a lot of
you know how can we put this real
serious crimes committed
and do you think part of this is just
guilt looking back and saying we've
really messed up here we need to really
make sure we're hot on all the subject
matter and all these political topics so
that no one can ever accuse us of being
racist
sexist etc perhaps but i think they need
to look at they need to get back to the
core message what is the church for
what's it about it's about jesus christ
it's about evangelizing it's about
discipling the name the nations and it's
about
teaching people the truth the way in the
life it's as simple as that they just
need to return to the book return to the
bible do what it says in the bible
promote those messages
if there's a big fight going on in the
secular state let the politicians
discuss it and let them bang it up bash
it out but the church doesn't need to
keep getting involved in party political
matters and this is why i've come to
conclusion that actually maybe the
church of england needs to be
disestablished maybe it needs to be
separate to take the church away from
the state
so that we can have actually have people
going to the church if they want to look
after the spiritual well-being but not
have the bishops
involve themselves
in part of political matters
and calvin do you think
maybe an alternative explanation to the
one that france has posited is that
we know that the church of england is
not doing well
by historical standards it's in decline
let's say do you think there's maybe
part of it where they sort of like
everyone wants to capture young people
nowadays television comedy ever young
people you know we've got to get the
young people and and so maybe if we go
woke we're going to get the young people
to join the church they're all now if
we've got a trans flag on on top of the
spire then then then everything then
then we're gonna get the people to come
in and pray which they're not doing 100
it's the same as the bbc isn't it it's
like attracting an audience that doesn't
actually exist they're trying to be
overtly work they're trying to be very
liberal progressive and think this is
what the young people want let's attract
these you know the let's get the trendy
young people it's like that i'm one of
you fellow kids it's that
it's so cringe it's embarrassing and the
church shouldn't be trying to chase
societal norms anyway on any of these
issues because the church should be
counter-cultural it should be an
alternative to put it scripturally it
should be a shining light in an ever
darkening world around us because people
are sick and tired a lot of people are
sick and tired of what's going on around
us we're sick and tired of being lied to
you know being told there are 99 genders
so you can identify as a horse if you
want to these i've been using a
ridiculous example but this is stuff
that's actually going on people know the
truth they know there's just male and
female people know that
well
if being white doesn't make you racist
and being black doesn't make you a
victim
and
when they get sick and tired of what's
going on around them in the state they
should be looking towards something
different alternative but if the church
isn't offering that where are they going
to go well this is why people end up in
these stupid things like extinction
rebellion because not only are people
looking for
a truth
rather than the truth people are also
looking for a sense of belonging a
community a place to be a family and if
these wacky groups are offering it and
the church isn't they're going to join
the wacky groups what really bothers me
about this situation as well cameron is
like as i said i'm not a churchgoer i
don't go to church it's not an important
part of my life but i also i don't want
to live in a society where i was the
same right people should be allowed to
to have christian conservative views
like we have christian conservatives
that work on the show right and we have
arguments and disagreements over the
dinner table as we talk about this stuff
and it's interesting and it's the spice
that adds to the mix right difference
but it seems to me like all the
institutions they they've all got to be
the same way yeah right and there would
have been a past in the 1930s or 40s
where it was the other way around it was
all like that right
but i just i it seems to me like we're
over swinging in the other direction
where everything is becoming homogeneous
and everyone has to think the same
otherwise you're evil bigot or whatever
oh absolutely like i have very strong
opinions on these things but that
doesn't mean i'm right and i'm willing
to debate them and have my ideas
challenged but it seems the opposition
isn't so in these emails i saw from the
bishops for example when i championed a
petition against lament to action that
ridiculously crt infested report the
bishops had a conversation amongst
themselves and said well it looks like
we're right on this then if carvin
robertson is opposed to it it's like
that's how they're affirming that they
are right they're not engaging in
conversation they're not saying actually
here's an ethic minority within the
church that has a different perspective
to what we're used to let's take that
one on board too and look at the wider
picture it's like no this is a
right-wing loon so we must be right
i just can't believe because you've
never been someone who's shied away from
what you believe in you've always been
very forthright you've always been very
honest
so i then look at it and then go well
why did they bring you in
exactly why have they invested all this
money
in order to you know to give you this
training and wonderful education at
oxford
in order just to
basically prevent you from being
ordained it doesn't make any sense no it
doesn't because i suppose for them to
say no they'd have to be open and honest
at some point and they've never been
open or honest with me even now when i
sit down and have conversations with the
bishops it's all it's very political
it's you know if you ever spoke to
someone where they can give you 100
words you still don't get a meaning from
it
yeah i'm like i don't know what you're
trying to tell me just be you know i try
to say what i mean and i mean what i say
and i really respect when other people
can do that but when they're talking
around the subject and getting all
political it tells me they're actually a
politician and they're not a pastoral
figure
but they've never been open and honest
at the beginning they could have said
look we don't see we don't think you're
a good fit for the church of england
we're not going to take you forward to
training but then they might have had a
discrimination case or something they
might be afraid of that kind of thing
but even now they've not said look we
don't want you in the church of england
or we don't like your views this again
it's not we don't like your views it's
how you say them like they lie around
the topic or they say you know come back
in a year time or two years time and see
if things have changed like you know my
stance on these issues you know what
kind of person i am you know what i
stand for you don't seem to like any of
those things i don't know if they're
going to have changed in a year's time
just be honest and say we don't want
people that are conservative politically
or theologically in the church we are
looking to go forward as they call it in
a liberal progressive way that's your
that's your preferred route
just tell me
do you think there needs to be some kind
of legislation
from the government and i know that
you're probably
not very
lefty yeah
um but
i think it's come to a point now why is
it acceptable to discriminate against
somebody with legitimate political
opinions simply because you don't share
them
but you can't discriminate against race
sex gender and all of those things which
i agree with why is it absolutely
acceptable to disagree with somebody to
say to somebody and discriminate against
them because they have
different political opinions
i mean you have a good point i don't
know the argument against it i've been
saying for a long time we need to get
rid of the equalities act i don't like
the protected characteristics idea
but the other argument is just flood it
with more protected characteristics you
know political ideas could be a
protected characteristic and then people
might have a defense as long as it's
used as a defense and not as a weapon
and you know kimmy badlock's really good
on this and saying it's been used as a
sword far too long it should be a shield
and i get that argument but
this is the problem with the legislation
it's not always interpreted in the way
it's intended
calvin we're going to get questions from
you guys in a second so send in the
super chat if you want us to pose your
questions in a few minutes for calvin
but what i was going to ask you kevin is
do you think there's a problem for
religion in general and for the church
in particular because
what you're talking about as the role of
religion is to
articulate and pass down certain
let's let's call them from your
perspective truths things that aren't
true
they are the word of god and
there's a rigid certainty to them
yet the world that we now live in
increasingly is very subjective it's
your lived experience it's your feelings
it's your truth it's your and so there
is an inevitable contradiction between
those two positions and it seems that
the church is now moving in that
direction and you are one of the people
who's going no no that's not the role of
the church do you think that is the
conflict at the heart of this i do think
you're spot on there and i think that's
why a lot of people are lost because
it's helpful to know that there is a
universal truth that we're striving
towards or
the pursuit of knowledge uh whether
you're christian or enlightenment
there's it's the same angle whereas
nowadays it is all subjective is your
own your own truth and if you own your
own truth you invent your own reality if
you that's that's pretty much a fantasy
but the problem there is that you expect
everyone else to take on board your
fantasy and that's when we get into
cases of so-called discrimination or
offense or hate crime because people
aren't living in your reality i don't
think that's acceptable but what the
church should be doing is teaching the
objective truth which
to a christian is god is jesus christ
but
you know so many times people say to me
the church has changed its teaching on
on homosexual marriage or on abortion
or
whatever and i'll say no it hasn't the
church has just stopped talking about
these issues the teaching remains the
same the doctrine remains the same
because the bible remains the same you
can't change these things all that's
happened is the church has become
embarrassed
about the faith because it doesn't want
to be seen as bigoted or whatever or out
of date or out of fashion so it stopped
telling people the truth and now people
don't know it anymore and that is such a
good point because the reality is
if you're going to interpret the bible
in its in its most literal in its most
honest way you can't possibly be woke
they're fundamentally incompatible
absolutely
and that's why we have the problem we
have because people have stopped
returning to the bible
including the hierarchy of the church of
england but you mentioned is this the
end for the faith in general i don't
think it is i think there are many many
solid christians in this country not as
many as they used to be but i think a
lot of that is people were always
nominally christian and because it was
the done thing as an
englishman you were a christian whether
you went to church or not you were just
a christian and now it's not the dumb
thing it's not the you know it's quite
unfashionable to say christians so all
those nominal christians have moved away
from they're no longer in the data but
the actual christians the practicing
christians still are
thriving and the problem we have is the
monopoly of the church of england
because it's established you know
anglicanism
is a broader movement than just the
church of england but people see it as
synonymous now if it was separated
churches state and the church ring
didn't have a hold on all the churches
and on all the institutions and all of
that business
other anglican bodies could thrive and i
think that would be helpful for the
people of this country as well as the
roman catholics and other denominations
they'd have more of a foothold
in the country if it wasn't all down to
the church of england
all right so before we go to our
audience questions kevin what is the
future for you then with all of this uh
because uh you know whatever people
think about your views i don't think
anyone can deny that you're exactly the
sort of person that should have a voice
in our society
they can disagree with your views but i
think you're intelligent i think you're
articulate i think the way you
communicate your ideas is helpful rather
than unhelpful which there's a lot of
going on at the moment right uh you have
a prominent voice people listen to what
you have to say like
whether people agree with your views or
not you should have a role in society
certainly in my opinion
so how is that how is that going to
manifest itself now because this is what
you want i know you you know you're
going to be hosting your show on gb news
and you do other stuff but i think the
church is where you want to be yeah so
what's the future hold for you now
absolutely so i'm not i don't feel
called to full-time
broadcast i love having a platform and i
love using gb news to spread the good
news but i don't think i'd ever be a
full-time broadcaster i'm called to
ministry and i get to do that partly
through broadcast but i'd love to do
that in a parish setting and i also
think there are a lot of people in this
country that feel that the church of
england has left them rather than them
leaving the church that's how i feel i
think the church has left me it's gone
woke it's gone anti-christian and i feel
like i've stayed the same so i what i'm
gonna do is plant a church in london for
people who think similarly to myself
that want to be orthodox anglicans uh
they can come along with worship
together on a sunday have a good time
and just be true to the faith
all right guys well uh we're gonna come
back with all your questions and some
more from us in a second but we're gonna
take a quick break i'm gonna do that now
and we'll see you back here in a couple
of minutes with all your questions
hey constantine do you want better
mental health i'm from russia we don't
have mental health so how do you deal
with mental health you drink vodka then
go out and wrestle bear if you live you
feel better if you die you're not real
men what about the bears feelings it's
russian bear it has no feelings people
don't always realize that physical
symptoms like headaches teeth grinding
and even digestive issues can be
indicators of stress and let's not
forget about doom scrolling not sleeping
enough sleeping too much under eating
and overeating sleeping too much under
eating this is western disease therapy
has really helped me in my life to
concentrate and focus it's really
important to have someone impartial you
can talk to about the tricky issues that
you're struggling to deal with therapy
has played a really important role in
helping me to deal with my adhd and
become better in all areas of my life
why is he telling them how weak he is
drink vodka feel better better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to trigonometry funds get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com forward
slash trigger especially if they're not
real men that's b e t t e r h e l p dot
com slash trigger
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy dns is a company for you easy dns
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture the
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy dns have
rock-solid network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is go to easydns.com
forward slash triggered that's
easydns.com
forward slash triggered use our promo
code which is also triggered and get 50
off the initial purchase sign up for the
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
hey francis what do you think is the
best way to advertise a business that's
easy all you need to do is spend shed
loads of cash on an advert that's going
to be promoted on a dying medium like tv
then simply sit back and watch all your
hard-earned money disappeared down the
toilet what about advertising with
trigonometry why would i do that when i
can advertise on itv3 for the measly sum
of 20 grand and be watched by six people
because trigonometry now has over 350
000 subscribers across the different
platforms and gets 2 million views and
downloads a month that's right you can
place an advert with us and we'll
promote your brand on one of our
episodes your adword will be written by
two professional comedians yeah that's
right we're hiring two professional
comedians
when we make our ads funny and engaging
to the point where some people say the
ads are their favorite parts of the show
yeah we probably shouldn't admit that
mate all you need to do is contact us on
marketing at triggerpod.co.uk
that's marketing at triggerpod.co.uk
advertise with us and we'll get your
business cancelled
hello and welcome back to the second
half of the interview where you get to
ask your questions to calvin robinson
that was very smooth by the way you just
went you had your thumb up for about two
seconds and then you went
hello and welcome back to
there we go we're gonna take your
questions if you want to ask a question
of calvin send in the super chat we're
also going to do a bunch of questions
from locals if you're not already on
locals as a supporter make sure you get
on there but anyway fire away francis
okay so the first one is from napoleon
blown apart what does faith offer that
atheism cannot
everlasting life
simple as that i mean if you don't
believe in something greater than
yourself
where do you get your humanity from or
where do you get your accountability
from but also christ offers us
everlasting life in god so i think
that's something to to look towards it
was actually one of the points i was
going to make when we were having the
conversation earlier because
as a for the 50th time non-church going
person the one thing that appeals to me
about
a faith-based structure
is the reminder that you're not the
center of the universe and that there's
something above you
and
that is important whether you believe in
a bearded man in the sky or not
that without that human beings are lost
and they
you know we find ourselves in a very
dark place very quickly
but if you if everything's subjective
and and you get to choose your own
everything and there's no truth
then that's the only way to be isn't it
this is a it's a counter balance to a
problem so the left cent tend to be very
collectivist uh and they depend on the
state to solve all the problems and on
the right we tend to be more
individualistic and say you know the
individual has their own freedoms their
own rights and responsibilities and
their own choices to make but then the
individual becomes the god
and we again we are in the same problem
as the left so the faith meets somewhere
in the middle actually and says actually
we are individuals and we all have our
own rights responsibilities but we're
all also
obliged to take care of each other and
that this is communitarianism isn't it
there's a central ground there and i
think with most arguments there is a bit
of a nuance and the faith provides the
nuance for societal issues and i think
that's one of the problems with our
society is even on the left it's all
about me it's all about identity who i
am and it's this constant focus on the
self
that just ultimately means you're going
to become very miserable yeah it's just
what is narcissism isn't it we see it
everywhere that's what the whole trans
movement is that's what a lot of these
issues are that are arising at the
moment is that people are putting
themselves at the center of their own
universes they have no accountability
they have nothing higher than themselves
to humble them so of course everything
just gets blown out the window people
are very miserable very unhappy and
mental health crisis is shooting through
the roof
all right well uh so we've got a ton of
questions on local so usually we just do
two and put them out on locals only but
instead we'll do a bunch from locals
and we've had some super chats i've seen
that thanks anton so uh this one is from
uh short bird
and she says uh i'm gonna do her
question in reverse order because the
question is fairly interesting and
provocative perhaps but uh she also she
also says just wanted to say that
although my ideas and aspects of life
differ massively from calvin's i really
like him and wish him all the best he
comes across as a very decent man
wrong i know um
but she does say why does calvin not
believe in women being ordained
well what has he got against burns mate
yeah it's not in the bible
the christian faith is based on the
bible but if it's not in the bible it
shouldn't be happening i i
people try to make it about equality and
and
and human rights and all that kind of
stuff but it's not about that so the
bible says that we are all equal but
that doesn't mean we're the same we're
very different the rules between men and
women are very different we've seen that
in recent years as we've seen more and
more men transition into women and just
destroy them at sports because we're
physically stronger there are
physiological differences
there are physiological differences
between men and women and but hold on
how does that relate to this because
christ chose men to be his bishops to be
his apostles that was a very active
choice christ
chose when he came to work when he
became mad incarnate he chose when to be
he chose how to be everything was on
purpose
and he had very important women in his
life the blessed virgin mary
you know he didn't say to her you will
be the first pope
he chose peter
there's a reason behind that
okay
so next question is actually a very good
one from clank he says or they say how
should christians today find communities
of people who aren't ideologically
biased and are open to intellectual
discussions
does this mean expanding your church
beyond london
um
well
so the first part of the question turn
off the internet
the internet is is
the devil's playground the internet is
why we are so siloed and tribalized and
so set against each other because we
find our own little group we find people
that are like us think like us and we
interact in that little lego chamber you
know i'm talking about the right as much
as the left on this because we find a
comfort zone and we're not used to
engaging with people that are different
to us anymore whereas the answer is to
go to church you've got young and old
black and white male female it's the hub
of the community it's your next-door
neighbors who might be an entirely
different line of work to you with from
an entirely different background that's
what's important that's where you get
diversity just go to good old-fashioned
church turn off the internet
i know i'm saying this on a broadcast on
instagram yeah
don't turn it off stay stay right here
go to the second part do i need to go
outside of london i think i'll probably
start very local i don't even think i'll
stream at first because i just want
people to be and to come and be it needs
to be in a place eventually i might do
some broadcast as well but we'll see
yeah
and bloody skies on local says is the
reason for the creep of wokeness and
church of england anything to do with
them now having to hire or not sac
agnostic or atheist vicars he says it
was rather surreal having a conversation
with the vicar that conducted my
father-in-law's funeral about his lack
of faith at the village pub afterwards
that makes me so sad
really does that no vicar should i mean
if they do have a faith crisis they
should see their spiritual director they
should not be putting that on to the
parishioners they shouldn't they're
there to preach about god that is there
to tell people that god is true god
loves them and god is here and present
with them an ever living god
so to suggest that that person that
vicar is having a crisis he needs to see
he needs to seek help
help elsewhere that's inappropriate it
makes me very sad to hear that
i mean that
doesn't that just say a lot though about
the state that the church is in where
you've got a vicar who doesn't even
believe in what he's saying so what's
the point i know
i think i feel like you can get by if
you don't believe if you are agnostic or
even atheist you can get by in the
church and it's when you're affirming
the faith that they get worried
it's back to front it is completely back
to front it's it's very it's just very
very sad
okay so
next question uh
is from uh
cabeza de brasil which means is it for
you to say yeah it is it is it is easy
means empty head
okay and they i say and the question is
who is your favorite church father and
why and what would they say about the
culture today oh
well one of them would be augustine i
don't think he'd have anything nice to
say about this uh probably because he
you know he started the church of
england um aquinas was very anti-woke um
on a lot of these issues
uh i mean we didn't read any church
father and they're very affirming in
their catholicity in their christianity
and
very counter-cultural
benedict
the benedictines were you know
the first proper monastic movement of
living outside of the world so we're
called to be in the world but not of the
world and they were like you know we
need to set something separate so we
need to be that candle in a dark window
ledge that people can see and get
attracted to and know that there is an
alternative to the to the nasty
or horrible secular world around them
so i don't know which one would be my
favorite but there are lots that are
inspiring but of course
i try not to have heroes because when
you have heroes you fall into idolatry
uh if there's one person to look to it's
jesus christ
very own brand
i was gonna say calvin do you think the
church has got an image problem in that
if you
make fun of another religion that is
seen as punching down
but
we see it with stand-up for instance if
i went out and did a load of jokes on
stage about islam
things are going to get quite spicy to
put it mildly and not just from from
muslim people but it's going to be from
people in the audience oh yeah whereas
if i go on stage and do a load of jokes
about christianity i mean that's
it's kind of hack
at this point
you wouldn't really get many laughs
because it's been punched at so much
yeah it's about niche kumar isn't it you
know unfunny yeah but the bread rolls
will be out yeah
no i think you're right um it's that
self-flagellation it's because we are a
christian country you know we're
anti-british we're anti-christian and
that's appropriate that's acceptable
because we've got such a terrible
history we need to move beyond it i
understand there's probably been a few
years of you know over correction
because we have had some hormones in our
past but we've reached a point now we've
got to come back and we've got a the
pendulum has got to swing the other way
and we've got to be proud to be british
and proud to be christians not too proud
because it is in but enough to be
supportive and patriotic
yeah
someone called woman on our local so
she's a bigot says party time uh imagine
that it's a party would you rather be
enjoying yourself with ten atheists from
the free speech union or ten christians
from the higher echelons of the church
of england easy free speech every time
that's what i do most of them are free
there we go uh francis do you want to do
another super chat well like okay all
right so
let's see what we've got we have got
okay we've got some more coming in uh
let's have this
so this is ikea and he says the neon
marxists are going after freedom of
speech and freedom of conscience
shouldn't the church of england be
worried that freedom of religion is next
it's a great question and then the
second part of that question is are you
worried calvin i'm very worried i really
am we've seen with the conversion
therapy bill
um they want to ban prayer you know
freedom of religion is going downhill
conversion therapy is all illegal you
know electrocution is already illegal um
rape corrective rape is already illegal
the only things that are additional
really are therapy and prayer
and once they are in the legislative
once they are laws in our land they will
be used against us you know at the
moment if you have
a young man for example who's saying i
want to live
a life in christ i want to live a
celebrate life until i'm married to a
woman
and i'm being
having impure thoughts please pray for
me
that would be illegal under the bill
it would be legal for the person to pray
for them
likewise if you're an adult who's
married wait why is that illegal because
it's conversion that's that's what this
bill is it's about
not being able to support people in
conversion whether it's with its
sexuality or trans
genderism
because it's seen as
coercive right okay
so they don't want people to be
persuaded like this is a mass thing
that's going on we're going around
persuading people not to be
actually we're sending them straight off
to to get their bits chopped off and
converted or giving them puberty
blockers which i think should be illegal
because
there is no such thing as a trans child
if an adult wants to make a decision to
do something with their body that's up
to them but for a child they should be
supported and loved and encouraged by
their parents and to have their body
mutilated is is an offense it's neglect
and or abuse but anyway
we have we have reached the point where
freedom of worship is being threatened
in this country already in scotland they
had that bill i forgot what it was
called now but
you could
be
reported for a hate crime in your own
home for preaching the gospel if someone
finds it offensive
this is the way we're going
i mean
it is incredibly worrying
i find that bill shocking i find that
bill absolutely shocking and the thing
that i find possibly even more shocking
is that there hasn't been a massive
ferrari about it well even worse than
that a load of people signed a petition
against it saying look these are the
dangers of it you're going to make it
illegal for people to pray for people
or even illegal for someone to give
someone therapy if they choose to take
it
the church and the vast majority of the
hierarchy of the church petitioned
against the petitioners saying you guys
are bigots and xenophobes and racists
and homophobes and transphobes it's like
no we're standing up for scripture and
you guys are actually actively opposing
us what is going on well calvin very
much on that point and this is a
conversation that we often have in here
with our criso friends um
ebl who's a big supporter of us she says
uh how does the church of england stay
relevant in the society that has changed
immeasurably over the last 50 years in
terms of social norms and how people
view themselves and the world around
them where does it stand firm and where
does it need to bend and this is the
conversation we often have because you
know some christians have a very sort of
that hard line interpret like you
perhaps you know this is in the bible
this isn't in the bible
but the church does change over time i
think we'd all recognize that the church
now is not the church of a thousand
years ago right for shame
so you actually think we should go back
a thousand years relevance is irrelevant
it's not our job to be relevant to the
secular world around us because like i
said progress isn't linear so we make
mistakes you know rome fell in the end
and i feel like sometimes it feels like
we're at the fall of rome again in our
western society where we're up is down
bad is good uh right is wrong so we
shouldn't be chasing these norms we
should not be trying to be relevant we
should be static we should say this
these this is the faith passed down to
us from the apostles
who christ chose this is our this is our
universal catholic faith apostolic faith
and we are here to evangelize based on
scripture not based on any anything else
and
we do worship we still worship things
but we worship completely different
things now don't we
in particular the acquirement of
material goods and possessions people
believe that if they have wealth
success particularly financial success
that somehow it's going to make them
happy send us a super chat yeah please
do uh my man was in the bible it's
nothing is new you know we've seen it
all before all these issues were in the
bible
yeah you know if jesus christ came to us
today he'd be cancelled the church
wouldn't accept him we'd think he was
too or controversialist they'd think he
was too outspoken and bigoted and all of
these things that they'd probably sharp
crucify him crucify him just as they did
2000 years ago
john bryce says do you think workism is
now irreversible irresistible sorry or
are there effective strategies for
pushing back against the ideology i see
lots of people describing workism but
few discussing how to actually resist it
you know i'll say the same thing i said
last time i came on we all need to stand
up we don't need to stick our heads
above the parrot bits some of them will
get chopped off but that's a risk we
have to take we have to be martyred for
the cause and if we all stand up they
cannot cancel all of us but until we
stand up they're going to keep pushing
back and they are the vocal minority and
the the loudest voice in the room so we
need to drown them out because we are
the majority
i i agree with you completely and there
was a question from somebody on locals
uh about how you became motivated or
what inspires you to do that to stick
your neck out just had enough really
hard enough yeah right even when i was
teaching
i was writing publicly about the
left-wing indoctrination that i was
seeing and you know there are other
people that call themselves secret
teacher or this and that and not wanted
to disclose who they were i thought no i
want to own this i truly believe what
i'm seeing in schools is wrong and i'm
going to put my name on it and that's
what led me to where i am today and we
see of course there's this big twitter
account uh libs of tick tock or whatever
which exposes what a lot of in america
teachers are saying and what they're
teaching their kids is that someone i
mean you probably wasn't quite as
extreme when you were teaching but is
that the type of thing that you were
starting to become aware of absolutely
it's abhorrent but i think if people if
parents saw what was being taught in
schools they'd be going nuts but of
course we just send our kids off and
trust it's all going to be all right
it's going to be rosie dory and they're
just going to teach them the abcs and
the ones plus ones equals twos but no
two plus two now equals five and and the
teacher is telling the kids about their
own sexuality and um what underwear
they're wearing today and i'm not even
making this up this is a legitimate
example is is what underwear they're
wearing yeah there was a teacher
recently that wore a male teacher that
wore ladies underwear and he started a
club uh talking about sexuality and he
wanted to come out to his kids as was it
pansexual one of these made up
sexualities anyway you know ten years
ago if someone had done that whatever
their sexuality you go that's a nonce
you know what yeah it is it isn't it's
grooming it's this is a big problem in
the left there's a lot of grooming going
on all of this
sexualizing young kids is grooming we
used to think it was illegal and nasty
and wrong and now somehow we're
supporting it as progressive and this is
what i mean when i say progressivism
isn't literally linear because we're
seeing you know what was that play that
lawrence helped get cancelled um oh the
family sex show yeah the family sex show
those words should not go together
it's you know it's demonic
come on the church the church has a big
problem so careful now i'm sorry calvin
wouldn't want to be associated with
anything it's cornwall
there's gonna be at least two people
having him meltdown about this i'm gonna
get someone messaging me that's all
right
uh this question is is it it's a little
bit more left-field it's from the king's
lobotomy and he says can you ask names
today yeah can you ask calvin to talk
about his walkout on the now famous
oxford union vegan speech oh my gosh so
this so i'm all for open debate yeah and
i'm all for disagreeing well but at some
point you have to say this is lunacy i
cannot there is no common ground to be
made here and this was what happened so
this was michaela peterson i went there
to support her she was debating um she's
a massive carnivore she's debating her
favorite meeting meet against some
vegans and most of the arguments were
sound you know i don't agree with them
but there were sound arguments and this
woman got up i can't remember her name
or where she's from
but she said that eating meat is
colonialist white supremacy racist
sexist is there another history isn't i
missed out
there's always another one it was all of
them and i was like
i cannot engage with you this is not
this is not realistic this is not this
you're living in a fantasy world there's
there's nothing to be gained from
listening to this lunacy i just got up
and walked out and i you know i spoke to
jordan peterson afterwards he was
laughing his head off at it but
obviously he had to stay in support
michaela but it's just there has to come
a point where say enough is enough i'm
not going to entertain your lunacies
anymore
you know you're not in the real world
and
that was one of those examples yeah and
cameron we've got a question uh from our
big supporters resin pes uh and i think
it's she that says mr robinson will
atheists be welcome in your church would
be quite happy to debate the old
testament teachings as an ex-born again
christian now i warn you ronnelle is
pretty feisty
everyone is walking in my church church
should be welcome and inclusive to
everybody
but welcome what about non-christians
everybody but they're welcome to be
changed through an experience with
christ
that's that is true inclusivity it's not
about watering down my values or the
church's values or christian values to
make anyone else feel comfortable or to
not offend people they are welcome to
come but they're welcome to become to be
joined and changed through an experience
in christ a minecraft by the way says
please just send love and support for
our calvin you're like the nhs man
every thursday we're going to bang some
pots and pans for you
and punished opinions as well uh with
the two quid super chat says what of the
problem of apostolic succession in
church i have no idea what that means
but that is another issue with yeah so
the way that christ chose the apostles
because it's a faith rooted in tradition
um so the bible is the word of god but
the bible comes from tradition it comes
from many different stories put together
um and it was it was told through word
of mouth before it was written down and
they as the apostles started to die out
they started we started to get these
things written down but the apostles
have handed this tradition down to us in
form of the bible and other
and other practicing tradition now
when someone is consecrated a bishop
it's said that you know it's handed down
from the apostle to the next person to
the next person to the next person
that's the lineage that's the apostolic
obsession and that's broken
when
we ordain a woman because it's not a
valid order
because women can't be priests or
bishops
there's plenty of leadership laws for
women but
being a priest in persona christi you
know in the person of christ is not
legitimate and not valid therefore
apostolic succession is being broken in
this country and that if a woman bishop
ordains a man that that man would not be
validly ordained in many people's eyes
so it's it's quite problematic
well there we go um
i think we'll wrap up there
thanks for coming back all the best to
you with with what you're doing and uh
the new church
um and i think there's a lot of people
who are looking for something that's
untainted by ideology at this point
because the one thing i suppose i would
imagine is
even in the way that you conduct
yourself you would be welcoming of
people with different opinions uh and
you wouldn't be excluding them and i
think there's quite a lot of people who
there's an appetite for that let's say
uh there's an appetite for it in terms
of conversations on youtube and i'm sure
there's an appetite for that in in terms
of the religious space as well so all
the best of luck to you i'm sorry you've
had this experience but i know you'll
come out of it uh stronger and better so
thanks for coming back on the show and
we look forward to seeing you again and
thank you guys for watching and
listening uh we'll be back with raw in
literally a couple of hours the first
one since we've been away so we'll see
you in a couple of hours take care see
you soon god bless